a pacman shaped ukelele and a
heavy-metal t-shirt it's episode 13 of
loot this is a ticking time bomb the
longer you wait the more pieces will
wind up soggy except with the O bowl you
decide what pieces get wet and win and
these wine glasses let you control wet
stuff musically the markings on the side
tell you where to fill for a specific
note when running your finger over the
rim Luna and curious offer Bonnie tights
with a hidden gun and socks that make
you look like a duck but for you men if
you want to look classy and up cycled
check out these ties they're made out of
wood from demolished barns they're also
a perfect companion to these no wash
Underpants the Front's yellow the backs
brown no worries but if you do plan on
practicing some hygiene do it in the
dark with this glow-in-the-dark toilet
paper from fire box now if things get
smelly but you want to maintain
manliness use unmanned can these candles
smell like bacon sawdust New York style
pizza a new leather baseball mitt
and more okay the classic coca-cola
bottle shape please I prefer the
original Hutchinson can as part of their
125th anniversary you can own the
bottles entire history now if you like
heat and sweet drizzle spicy chili
pepper and boost hot honey on your pizza
they even say it goes well in t stay
fancy with think geeks science jewelry a
pendant that also is a functioning
sundial and this 8 bit hair bow then
play a game of poker with some toast
playing cards the Joker's are eaten and
burnt Japan trend shop also carries this
desk lamp suspended by its pill then
relax in a replica Big Lebowski of the
dude cardigan the one used in the movie
auction for more than 10 thousand
dollars but now the company that
originally made it is offering a replica
for a hundred and eighty eight you can
wear it and lounge around listening to
your iPhone or iPod in a nice loud
gramophone station not sticky enough
we'll try out neato shops phone stand
that looks like bubblegum and be sure to
use the kick to pick app that balances
on a pregnant belly cycles through
possible baby names and uses the phone's
accelerometer to detect baby kicks so
that your baby can choose its own name
before it's even born transfer files
with these fried shrimp USB memory
sticks or a super slim bookmark that is
also a two gigabyte flash drive now it's
time for something free the font that
coca-cola is written in it's just the
way people used to be taught how to do
cursive back at the turn of the century
it's called Spencerian handwriting and
it was replaced later on by the Palmer
method which for instance Mickey Mantle
used and today we learned that the Neil
Ian method but anyway what that means is
that coca-cola obviously owns the
trademark for their brand name coca-cola
but they don't own the copyright
on the specific script it's written I
mean from crying out loud
the Ford Motor Company uses the same
script so there you go have fun using
your free public domain ancient cursive
style and as always thanks for watching